what's up guys welcome to day two of
GameSpot cross kind of funny at e3 as
always I'm Tim Geddes i'm joined by
alfredo di my best friend that's where
we're doing now cross see if every
operation got physical chugging throw it
up you throw it up man it's hard
sometimes we're joined by three four
threes best chris and kevin hello hey
guys so much for being here no worries
i'm gonna talk a little bit about halo 5
awesome now what you guys showing at e3
about a low five yeah so we started off
the week at the media briefing showing
our epic new campaign we showed a
mission featuring Spartan Locke and
fireteam Osiris during the media
briefing and then we gave folks a little
tease of war zone at the briefing and at
the show floor we have war zone playable
and it's our new massive multiplayer
mode that's 12 e12 pvp and PVE so those
little thought process and bring war
zone into the Halo universe I mean that
back just a bit kind of game mode well
it's Halo fans ourselves and developers
you know we always wanted to get
everything in one place and this for the
very first time with the power of xbox
one let us put all aspects of the halo
sandbox into one game mode and we needed
a really big big build mats for this so
we ended up with maps four times larger
than anyone's in for halo history so for
those people at home that aren't too
familiar with war zone can you give you
like a deep dive description about it
absolutely so you've got two teams to 12
as Chris mentioned yeah and you're going
to go out of your base which is under
attack at the beginning hit the
battlefield and you've got lots of
different options you can go after bases
and capture and hold those four points
you can go after these new AI bosses
which are worth a ton of points and
they're sort of like legendary editions
of ones we took from the campaign tons
of personality and those guys and
they're all different for each more zone
that and then you go after players as
well to contribute for your team so it's
a really intense competition we have to
have a lot of strategy so it's a game
over you can actually like contribute ya
no puedo Diaz we got mr. pro gamer over
here loves halo he's been playing halo
since he was a newborn child
to you yeah he's always was so into I
remember we met in high school bonding
over halo for some reason I thought it
was a cool idea to bring i had just like
DVD of a bike except like the original
halo was like a lamb tournament thought
it was cool to spring and put on my desk
for some reason yeah I don't like to get
I borrow that he's like yeah then we
became best friends so that's how that
works out but I was never good so he
would go out and shoot everybody and I
would just go capture the flag oh yeah
sneak around grab it run into a bush
hide I did eventually get in there so I
like this I like the idea of being able
to score points without killing yeah
going to the blade go after the AI
characters yeah yeah and then from there
try maybe he can drive your wart hog all
the war zones perfect because arena when
it's for before everyone has to be at
the same level yeah because of one
person can really bring the team down
and hurt you competitively but in war
zone you can bring in all your own stuff
with the requisition system so you could
call down a mantis while you're out
there with a sniper rifle getting all
those headshots and support each other
and play different roles on the
battlefield it's a really fun experience
that you know 12 e12 you can have
players of a variety of skill levels
playing and having fun and winning
together so an interesting thing about
is that there was always something that
you could do right yeah it usually like
another when you play big team battles
and you have these matches there might
be some like dead spots in between we
kind of wandering around but there's
always something to do here yeah and
it's really interesting though being
able to call in specific weapons that
you want and not having to like wait for
the response yeah well you know a big
team battle we never liked it when you
know four or five teammates with like
run after a big vehicle and then you
felt like you were competing over your
teammates or and it wasn't a great
experience for some players so went with
the requisition system we let you just
choose what you want and you mentioned
like all the different styles of play
like we have this big billboard that
says play your way yeah and we wanted to
make sure everyone who's coming into war
zone with your campaign player whether
your arena player you all found
something comfortable that you would
like to do so was it was it easy to kind
of get like the formula of war zone put
together you're like how'd that go I
don't think anything about making war
zone
the most ambitious mode we've ever had
in Halo game like having all those
players in there bringing the AI in
bringing every element of the halo
gameplay sandbox like power weapons
vehicles it's been a really challenging
process to kind of make it all work and
tune and iterate with 24 players the
team is on an incredible job but it's
something that you have to get so many
people together to play and kind of
iterate we have these playtests that go
like three times a day they play for an
hour make changes play for an hour so
it's definitely a labor of love and
something that we always dreamed of
making but it's been something that's
been a fun ride to try and make it happy
are the maps for war zone specific to
that mode or can you play them in other
modes as well no each of the war zone
mass is purpose-built for horizontal
yeah and each of the war zone mission we
treat them sort of like a mission
because there's so many different
personalities the boss is out there the
bases are aligned a little bit
differently and one of the things we've
discovered in developing these you know
when we went to four times bigger we had
our big bases then we had the vehicle
pass but when you go four times bigger
all of a sudden our airspace got bigger
oh yeah so we really started to develop
our aerial combat and we have a new
vehicle the forerunner Phaeton that's
just raining death on players is AI boss
and you can also go in and get it too
I've got my ass kicked by that vehicle
but then I saw just like it was very
interesting i was looking to the sky
ders like Austin all these vehicles were
fighting in the air and I was like oh
this is yeah it's like a bull hey old
shadow going on especially with the
Mantis I mean so many players used to
just run around stomping things in Halo
4 now you have to worry about banshees
here you firing the Rockets up in the
air much more it's also that's awesome
that so there's a really cool little
demo here yeah on the show floor but
with cludes halo and like the hololens
yeah I mean going it go to town on our
cuz that is awesome you have a surprise
that we wanted to bring the e3 we made a
special hololens demo specifically 43
that brings players on to the UNSC
infinity for a briefing with commander
Palmer before you go and play war zone
so you get to live this immersive
experience where you're actually all
aboard the affinity getting ready to go
into a Spartan warzone simulation that's
awesome everyone that's done it when
they walk out I see them they're like oh
my god that was so cool
want to be a part of that so yesterday
Cisco famous for the thong song yeah it
was on a show he was one of our
correspondents and we each have a game
of the year awards to get out and he had
us list the game that was the right here
let's bring it out this sport is heavier
than I thought it was so we have our
game of the year board that we all have
our choices so Cisco originally had the
Last Guardian as his number five but
then at the end of the day he came
through and he's like oh I just saw the
halo demo hey Lois my keep the show so
we wrote that put it there then he went
put the award over on you guys as a
booth so awesome awesome yeah awesome
thanks Cisco oh yeah my god so Kenya is
kind of going to detail in terms of like
the process of going in like what you
guys actually see and when it comes to
the hololens demo yeah yeah absolutely
you're gonna get the hall lens fitted
which and then walk through a briefing
room where they'll sort of give you an
introduction and the entire space is set
up to look like the inside of the UNSC
infinity and when I heard about this I
was just like well okay and then when
you go in there just this is real it
like it comes to life hello the first
the first moment where you're like whoa
is a waypoint comes up after you have
the hololens on your own you step into
the hallway it just bloop and a hologram
of a waypoint comes up in the real world
and it's just like I'm inside of a video
game this is so many experience I let's
just like reach you is this like oh yeah
to the idea of seeing blood goal should
being in Blood Gulch yeah that's
exciting I can only imagine it's the
possibilities right now you can I don't
know just just having like a map in
front of your table while you're playing
and then kind of enemies finger or
something I don't know yeah you could do
so many things yeah that's a hole at all
core experience yeah so then eventually
we get to have any fun yeah you get you
a briefing room and Commander Sarah
Palmer will sort of give you an overview
of what war zone is and then just as you
guys were mentioning they show you a 3d
version of arc which are a hologram
version of arc which is our the map
though we're showing off in war zone it
gives you a layout of where the bases
are and where some of the bosses are so
you kind of get like a tactical briefing
before you jump in wow that's really
so the whole fitting the whole bidding
process of the Holland's is an
experience in itself too right well it's
just so like amazing to have this piece
of technology and you it's very well
form-fitted there's like a little wheel
in the back you can adjust and then you
sort of get it right on your face and
fam that thing's you're ready to go what
was your experience with because you
actually did the demo yeah so what was
your experience doing it for the first
time I went in and I got bite my pupils
like yeah they measure the distance
between your pupils so that they can
make sure that everything lines up in
the hologram yeah yeah they gave to give
you like brought down that look like a
little number on like a car yeah it's
like okay this is all right and then you
go in you fit that on and it's a whole
experience like you don't really add it
it's when you said this all into the hut
then came up right yeah all I doesn't
have that just popped up and yeah there
was a cool experience yeah just Palmer
comes out of the table they show you
tactical information about the map and
they you can see it all in 3d so you can
get a really good idea of this spatial
kind of location of things in the map
you have the hunter and the bosses they
show you like really close ups of those
guys that you get to see with the device
and they're just like standing there on
the table there's a hunter standing on a
table in front of you during the
briefing yeah those guys are there not
that they're not pushovers no no yeah
the boxes in war zone are legit yes we
have some of our pro team or arena
players come in and they think I'll just
go solo that boss and they just run
after him and just get destroyed that's
all and then the next thing you know
they're looking over their teammates
like oh can you help me with this boss
so outside you guys to show off the
campaign because I the the trailers you
guys showed at the press conference oh
my god we were like whoa yeah so we are
really excited to finally start showing
the campaign we we spent a lot of time
redesigning rien visioning what we
wanted to do with campaign for halo 5
Guardians it's uh you know halo 5 is the
first game that's built for the ground
up for Xbox one so we made every
experience run 60 frames per second
dedicated servers including co-op
campaign so when you pick up the
controller and you start playing you'll
notice immediately you're a part of a 4
Spartan squad we call them fire teams in
both when you play as master chief or is
Spartan Locke they both have full fire
teams that are with them chief has the
blue team which if for fans of our
extended fiction like the halos all
agree you know that Spartans were are
taken as children and then trained and
genetically augmented to become Spartan
super soldiers and so the blue team is
basically the surrogate brothers and
sisters of Master Chief and in the
extended fiction fans and really know
what happened to blue team because it's
kind of left in a little bit of limbo at
the end of the story so we're bringing
them back and reintroducing players to
them so you get to see a chance to play
with Master Chief and kind of explore
more about chief interacting with people
that he has a really deep connection
with ya fireteam Osiris has Spartan
Locke and Spartan the fireteam Osiris it
are Spartan fours so they're very
different they're not abducted as
children they're the best of the best
from the military and then they're
they're selected for the Spartan program
so lock is from the Office of Naval
Intelligence and he is distinguished for
being able to capture high-value targets
so if you're going to go chase down a
legend like Master Chief you're gonna
want Spartan Locke to go and do that
mission and he's got with him Spartan
Olympia Vale who's a linguistics expert
from the Navy she specializes in sang
hee Lee which is the elite native
language comes in handy on Sing Sing
Helius yeah um you have Holly Tanaka who
survived the glassing of her homeworld
and has really become hardened and she
came from the Army and lastly we have
our fan favorite a Spartan Edward Buck
who you'll remember from ODST after
recently joined the Spartan program and
played by Nathan Fillion that's awesome
that because really cool he was like
yeah a lot of people like bucking and to
see him as a smart and it was like whoa
okay hold on oh man once we had our
announce my phone blew up because my
friend was like when we play co-op with
this game comes out I'm buck I was like
you can't tame smoke that it quickly
yeah that's so funny but one of my
friends back home he a huge fan as well
of the whole extended fiction of halo
and as soon as this what the blue team
was announced he's like I'm Linda by
what's this nightmare
I think it is very interesting the way
like the story is heading towards
because usually it's like okay yeah I'm
at your cheap and it you will have to
deal with the halo will have to do with
the company and then fly but now it's
like Spartans are Spartans it's
interesting like dynamic and oh you know
all the Spartans are you know iconic
right and at the same time it's like
well hold on like chief is what is he
doing I guess here is wrong and the
Spartans are hunting Spartans and it's a
whole interesting like take on the
mihaylo universe yeah yeah well in the
game we mission 2 is called the blue
team and chiefs team is sent to kind of
investigate a decommissioned Oni space
station called the argent moon as a
research center and at the end of that
mission they receive a mysterious
transmission of unknown origin and then
they go AWOL and that's when fireteam
Osiris is called in we got to find out
where the Master Chief is gone and what
he's up to so players will get to
experience an epic story that kind of
continues the saga of Master Chief that
we started in Halo four with him as the
central kind of plot of for the whole
camp campaign but you'll also get to
experience it from different
perspectives and play as the fireteam
Osiris so so there would you say that
halo 5 is a good jumping on point for
new people to get into the Halo universe
so I think uh we I think on Halo 4 we
had a little bit of really extended
fiction that was um you know we got in
brought in him from all of our different
kind of different transmedia properties
and I think that it was a little dense
for some folks in places but we know we
learned a lot from that and we halo 5
has to stand on its own and be a great
blockbuster triple a console shooter
experience so anyone that picks up halo
5 is going to have a great time get
introduced to this giant cast of
characters that we have and I think
that's good like that's late yeah from
what I hear about the campaign it sounds
like you're being introduced to a whole
bunch of new characters that no one's
really seen before unless you read the
books and stuff but you don't have our
rain down to know so it sounds it could
be a good point to jump on and the whole
you know lock vs chiefs storyline sounds
like it's gonna be a nice condensed
thing that also kind of expands for the
hardcore players and stuff so do you
also think that this is the halo game
that Halo fans have been waiting
for absolutely I think Lily we want to
make sure there's something in here for
everyone and it's like when you look at
our multiplayer kind of decisions as
well you look at arena we really wanted
to make that hardcore competitive mode
that you know fans from the legacy of
halo can really enjoy and I'm sure
you'll have fun sniping and pro gaming
people but then we also wanted warzone
this epic experience and campaigns no
different we want to make sure that's an
epic campaign that everyone is gonna
love to meet these new characters and
experience this crazy story that we're
gonna take you on so unless you guys a
hard question what's your favorite Halo
game judika first day right now it's
halo 5 I know yeah it'd be playing so
much of it over the last three years um
and just bores own with something we
always wanted to put together any of it
as a team we're like can we really do
this and like is this gonna happen are
we really gonna get all these vehicles
in one place with dozens of AI and once
it started coming together and the bill
started working we're just like this
this is real this is also yeah yeah I
love war zone halo 4 is always gonna
have a special place in my heart it is
our first title that we built as the
internal team at 343 but you know we've
played I love halo 5 like it's the game
we dreamed of making when we were making
halo for halo 4 is our first and it will
always be special but a low fives really
where I Australia working work making
this our own and kind of doing what the
ambitious things that we couldn't have
done in Halo 4 without the new platform
and just kind of understanding and
shipping something together as a team so
I mean how is that working on the Xbox
one down as opposed to 360 yeah oh it's
been a big difference there's a lot of
things we wanted to do in a holy halo
for that we just couldn't and now we can
with dedicated servers so just with the
size of the bases and the size of the
maps and all the I running it's all
being run on dedicated servers which
really makes war zone possible and also
we're building it from the ground up on
xbox one 60 frames per second up to
something that yeah we really want to
make sure that we make the best looking
Halo game ever and we wanted to run at
60 frames per second so it's like the
perfect time to make that switch and
harness the power of Xbox one
I think we we have a lot of great
features using the party system and live
dedicated servers it's been a great
experience for us and we're really
excited for people to be able to play
the game have you guys got your hands on
the new a week controller oh yeah
absolutely we have a few in house and as
Chris mentioned we have our pro team
that's been using them and giving lots
of feedback to those teams it feels
great in your hands the color is amazing
yeah yeah that's awesome so I got
imagine it fits right at home with Halo
and stuff are you guys doing anything to
like really support the pro community
and that eSports aspects us yeah yeah
yeah well our bait our beta was huge for
us I mean that was really aimed at our
competitive forum for arena players that
really are giving us the most feedback
on how we're going to shape this and we
made a lot of changes to sprint we made
some changes to the weapons and for the
first time we made changes to the maps
to which was awesome so what we're
really hoping to go out with a very very
fine-tuned competitive experience and
then support that later on with the hcs
or halo championship series which will
have more talk about later on perfect
yes that's awesome I mean the
multiplayer itself is just seemed like I
think the competitive scene is just have
always been around right and if they're
hard core group of people and I think
that supporting them would allow the
game to kind of carry on further than
than other games that don't have
multiplayer we completely agree and we
don't want to make any compromises I
mean like if you thought you were
talking about breakout that was a mode
that was just designed purely for
competition I mean it has fair starts
it's completely balanced it's a really
big driver for us to just make that as
competitive as possible and you said
he'd been thinking working on break out
that game on itself for a while or a
little while now yeah absolutely it's
one of the first things I tried to put
together at a 34 35 years ago yeah I
remember speedball pitch before you miss
called speed halo beat halo yeah and it
really just had a couple tenants it was
fast addictive competitive and it was
trying to merge paintball or speedball
specifically with halo yeah that's right
so we had a conversation earlier yeah
talking about paintball yeah you were
super to pay Paul for a while totally
inspired my deal
the [ __ ] i walk on with all this
like expensive gear and like the crazy
paintball go so he hasn't that you have
an antique you said yeah the autococker
yeah yeah so Gawker so the reason why
breakout kind of didn't make it into I
mean if it's something that's kind of
been pitch for four on five years the
reason why they jump in earlier well it
really was an ambitious mode I mean it
was hard to tell players they couldn't
respawn and if they hadn't played
paintball before he knows like what do
you mean I can't respond yeah and we
wanted to make sure that with Halo 4 we
proved ourselves that we could build a
competitive multiplayer experience get
all those kinks and then take on
something more ambitious like break out
in war zone on Halo 5 and I think in
Halo 4 we had a lot of things we wanted
to do as a team and we you know we have
to make sure that we get the key key
experiences into the game and we as a
team needed to figure out kind of where
our limits were and kind of what we
could put into a single yellow game and
now we're kind of pushing those
boundaries as we go forward and we still
have a lot of stuff we want to do and
kind of baked for our fans so once the
game's release this year and in
multiplayer is out what kind of tweets
are you guys expecting to make towards
towards multiplayer do too i would say
like community feedback yes so we've
made a lot of updates from the beta we
really took a ton of feedback from the
community we listened to the forums we
have the halo community feedback program
where people can sign up for that and
provide us feedback directly and we
looked at some of the core issues that
we had in all aspects of the game so
like the core gameplay we looked at
movement speed it was a big a hot-button
topic for the community so what we did
was we lowered the Sprint high in speed
and we raised the base movement speed to
kind of close that gap because we felt
sprint was a little too powerful in the
beta and so now we've got it into a
really good place and we've been play
testing and tuning using our pro team at
343 to make sure that was good that's
one example we we also felt that the
automatic weapons in smartlink mode
orchid doing a little too much damage
and we're a little too lethal and they
were kind of shifting the balance away
from hipfire too much so we brought that
back and we kind of tuned that down a
bit so that hip fire and smart
link have their clear distinct roles in
the sandbox and we but also rebounds
things between precision weapons and
automatic weapons a little bit and then
we change the maps as well we matched by
editing the maps important abilities
went through a bunch changes yeah ground
pound specifically the fans gave us all
sorts of feedback on that and we
completely overhauled the way that
feature works we got a little bit of a
different control now when you want a
ground pound because we had it on the
same button that was used for crouch
jumping what's with the Pro and hardcore
gaming community they definitely gave us
a ton of feedback about that right away
yeah so we move that to be on the mail a
button that's cool i really like you're
listening to the community because
they're the ones that matter you know
there's absolutely and we no one ever
want to break their braced up play style
too i mean crouch jumping was huge for
them it's a big deal to keep their heads
down and so we really want to maintain
that yeah uh-huh so ya alright I'm
alright so I'm hoping I no problem I can
answer I'm hoping we see Spartanburg
Spartan combat in the campaign I'm
assuming rule at some point we can't
we're only on showing this more just
like the thought of my hands over yeah
when I was watching that demos like oh
my whole demo he's really gonna use IA
it's gonna end with them fighting I was
like it was like if you if you see lock
find cheap I'm gonna lose my [ __ ] right
now like that's yeah I mean there
anything specific that you'd want to see
like in a campaign I know the campaign
sold me already like the the demo of
them walking and then like the ship
crashed or whatever and then like yeah
what the the road they were walking on
like I haven't had a jetpack and around
sprinting around I was like oh man that
looks fun the whole squad idea i think
is really cool and I like the
implementation in Halo 5 where it's not
so tactical and so like in depth where
you really need to focus on what
everyone's doing so much yes boy like do
you these people are going to be there
they're gonna support you and that's
really cool so how early into halo 5 did
you guys say okay we want to make this
squad base that was one of the things we
went to right away we really felt that
you know playing together with friends
as a key social component something we
really wanted to showcase in the
campaign it also like getting those
dedicated servers letting us build
seamless drop in and drop out co-op with
something that we felt like make it easy
for p
to get together and play and you know we
really wanted to make sure that that
whole campaign experience was built from
the ground up wit but we also didn't
want to isolate solo players either but
we wanted to have that fantasy of a
Spartan squad so we actually built a new
fire team AI system for players who
really want to play by themselves they
can they can issue a limited set of fire
team commands to the Spartan squad to
like pick up a weapon attack a specific
enemy drive this vehicle on those types
of things and they they can play through
the entire campaign and feel the
immersion of being inside of the Spartan
squad even without having your friends
online to play with you awesome wrapping
this up who's better at halo oh that's a
tough one I don't know Chris it depends
on the mode I gotta go now if it's a
halo mode it's probably me thank you so
much so much for being here yeah how
greedy thanks for having us gentlemen
somebody right back Thanks am I very
soon with way more footage on getting
spot cross kind of funny